ufc heavyweight tom aspinall gave his  fans an update on his knee injury that  he suffered 15 seconds into his  headlining bout with curtis blades at  ufc london on july 23rd in the video  aspinal revealed that he sustained heavy  damage to the knee tearing both his mcl  and his meniscus as well as inflicting  damage on the acl aspinall posted the  video right before heading into surgery  in london morning everybody  today is surgery day i'm in london right  now and uh  absolutely starving because i can't eat  before surgery and  [Music]  yeah i have suffered a torn mcl  a torn meniscus and  some acl damage so i'm gonna get that  fixed today but just a quick message  just to say thank you for all the  support really appreciate it i've had so  much love since uh the accident  and i'll see everybody on the side